the moment has come  centuries from now almost all humans  have lost the ability to see some say  sight was taken from them by God to heal  the earth for the few who remain vision  is only a myth but after so many years  the power of sight has returned  sometimes different children they have  the ability to see  [Music]  my children they have the power that we  would call magical or evil must protect  them  for centuries we feared this day would  come  the evil of light once almost destroyed  the world  and it has returned find the children  who can see  and Frank's time to me  now more complex if we kill the babies  they might leave us alone no I stand  with bah-bah-bah  is total hockey  they will bring knowledge that will  begin a new world  our family we are one we fight as one  [Music]  I have to keep you safe hello it has  come  it's astonishing how the smallest moment  can change an entire world  you  you